[Music]
when you think of sweden what comes to
mind
ikea
abba
maybe those delicious cinnamon rolls
but what about these swedish meatballs
right well maybe not
welcome to the meatball mystery
[Music]
let's cut straight to the chase it's
hard to make the swedes angry but on one
fateful day something happened that
fired up the whole country this tweet
was sent from the official sweden
twitter account swedish meatballs
actually based on a recipe from king
charles 12 brought back from turkey in
the early 18th century let's stick to
the facts
yikes did you catch that the tweet said
that swedish meatballs actually come
from turkey
as you can imagine the tweet went viral
swedes were up in arms it was picked up
all around the world
the swedish government has admitted
swedish meatballs are actually turkish
what what
no that's not a fact the facts is really
interesting since we don't have any
facts from that period wait who are you
my name is richard telstra and i'm a
food historian
okay here's what we know in the 1700s
swedish king charles xii lost a battle
in the great northern war he was forced
to flee to the ottoman empire where for
several years he negotiated his return
the controversial tweet suggested that
he brought back a local turkish meat
dish called koftas
however there is no documented interest
from him in food no mentioning of the
meatballs there they are not turkish
because we can't follow the original
meatballs in the world there is no
zero meatball where everything started
most likely already you know the
meatball is
a development in parallel ways in
parallel food cultures therefore
meatballs are very different all over
the world but they exist
all over the world today it's one of
sweden's most popular dishes
traditionally served with mashed
potatoes a brown gravy and a sweet
lingonberry sauce
[Music]
food gives us an example of how we are
connected
when it comes to culture food is a sort
of cultural network
so take pride in your meatballs sweden
and so should turkey china italy and
every meatball rolling country because
if there's one thing the world can agree
on it's that meatballs are delicious
[Applause]
bertrask northern sweden a small village
where you can get lit by magical lights
at night and during the day you can
worry about their great mystery
yeah somewhere between that house and
these cute reindeer and this giant row
of trees there is a centurion enigma
involving
cheese
yep this big
ball of cheese
[Music]
well as for all mystery towels a star
storyteller is essential and today that
is thomas
[Music]
is the emperor of swedish jesus i've
been making the vestibules nearly 40
years now
it was invented long time ago back in
1872
the maturation is at least 14 months
because a good cheese will take its time
it's a very unique taste
it has a bitter and milky flavour and
older the swedes love it they put it on
basically everything but for some reason
it can't be made anywhere else in the
world aside from this one factory
it's one of sweden's greatest mysteries
we have tried and made it in falcon bay
down in south of sweden also try to make
it in boldness and also in umeo
but it hasn't been the real vegetable
and cheese
we don't get the unique taste and flavor
of it
and why
no one really knows some blame it on a
meteor that struck the village some 20
000 years ago which created this lake
and in turn enriched the soil with
calcium which affects the cows in the
region which affects the milk and cheese
they produce
another theory suggests the cheese's
unique flavor is influenced by the
bacteria in the air of the old factory
building
i mean the air is so precious to the
cheese's flavor that when the building
expanded holes were made so the air from
the old building would flow into the new
one
there's a combination with the kind of
milk that we are using from the cows in
our region combined with the microflora
in our dairy if we call that magic or
not
okay
one thing is certain this magic cheese
is kept alive by the people working on
it i feel very humble for the fact that
i i'm allowed to work with this cheese
it's a bit of the the mystery that's why
it's special last thing can you give us
the recipe
no because that's the big secret with
this cheese
mystery solved
maybe
[Music]
good night
good night
[Music]
[Music]
three words you should never ask
what's
in
highest lum's liver
[Music]
well too late now let's do the story
[Music]
this is frasier mcgregor he's a haggis
maker i'm a champion huggers maker ah
he's a champion haggis maker here in
ding wall scotland at cockburn george
and sun and they don't hide their title
we're the first jumping huggers makers
in scotland we won the title in 1976.
chances are you've never heard of haggis
or at least you've never tried haggis
and that's because it's a very very
scottish dish hargis has been around for
centuries in scotland and it was evolved
hundreds and hundreds of years ago to
use up all the pieces of an animal
mainly lamb as in the lungs the liver
the heart that you would normally use in
everyday cooking
traditionally harvest is encased in the
sheep's stomach
fun fact these days stomachs are not
really used anymore they're actually
being made in non-edible casings which
are easier to cook with and they don't
have a
let's just say distinctive odor
making haggis is no easy feat to make
haggis from the start from the raw
ingredients it takes roughly 18 to 20
hours
first we cook the haggis ingredients
overnight then we sort the meats out we
mince it all together with the dry
ingredients and then after that goes
into the filling machine it is then put
into the boilers for the last and final
cooking and it's served any number of
ways
traditionally like this with potatoes
and turnips but today chefs they're
getting more creative
[Music]
the flavor of haggis is quite unique it
tastes savoury very rich you can't do
too much of it it's quite heavy as well
honestly we tried the haggis and it's
really good here anyway this secret
recipe frazier didn't actually make
himself the original recipe was
introduced into the shop by jockey
mccullum i worked with jockey for many
many years
i've now dabbled his number of years in
the shop so i think i can call it my
recipe now
to keep this tradition going is it's
quite hard in this day and age with the
cost of everything but we've tried our
best and obviously we're going to have
to keep it going and pass on to next
generation
can we see the recipe
no
you can buy the shop and then i can show
you
[Music]
oh the seashore
the waves the water
the seaweed
the sh sheep
are they eating seaweed
we gotta figure this out
[Music]
so here's a little context to start off
the story
we're in an island high high high up in
scotland called north ronald z it's so
remote you can only get here by ferry or
airplane
and on this small picturesque island
home to only 50 people lives a very
very rare breed of sheep
the seaweed sheep
[Music]
meet kevin the authority on all things
seaweed sheep
i am kevin woodbridge i'm the clerk to
the north romney sheep court which is a
fairly anciently established management
committee for all things sheep on the
island
so let's learn more about this rare
species welcome to seaweed sheep 101
[Music]
the chief investor coming to to walk
near
probably a thousand two thousand years
ago there was an orkney native breed
originally but these have branched off
into their own unique
niche which is just to live on seaweed
they are smaller than the average sheep
and their wool can be black white gray
or brown the males have big curly horns
and so do some females
and
they're only on north runs it's the only
place you can find them in the world
[Music]
in about the early 19th century they
were slowly excluded to the fortuna to
preserve the more fertile land in line
for cattle as a result the sheep were
confined to the seashore and were forced
to survive on seaweed this changed their
digestive system over time making them
one of only two animals in the world who
are able to survive on seaweed alone and
this wall known as the sheepdike makes
sure they stay on the shore right kevin
yes yes but um i think perhaps my
daughter heather is the best person to
speak to about that
okay well heather over to you
behind me is the native sheep dike um
this was constructed in 1832 the north
ramsey sheepdike is essential in the
genetic structure of the sheep
northrop sheep have a very high
intolerance to copper so they die from
over nutrition by grazing on the grass
for too long so we keep them on the
shore and they eat seaweed which has got
very low levels of iodine and copper
[Music]
the community has been very concentrated
on preserving and developing the sheep
the planting is obviously a big
community activity it takes everyone in
the island to turn out and chase them
along the beach and
clip them up and so on i think in many
ways they define the island it's very
much embedded in the in the island
culture and that's the heritage of the
island we need to preserve